all right and we all love the last word
with Lord kognito and ebon tiss fresh at
the campfire a little Friday evening
action but I even got some special
guests here going on today at KFI we do
the man joining us tonight is an awesome
fellow well-known in the community just
to be a lot of behind-the-scenes action
and you may not know him as well but
honestly one of the greatest guys in the
community that yeah he's out there so
I'm gonna pass it back so we can see if
we can get him to blush and turn the
color of his background so here we go
[Laughter]
episode number 99 wine away from 100 men
and it's another glorious Friday and
we're back in front of Kerr fire for
some more Luther shooter discussion I'm
extremely excited about our special
guests so we go get right into it
I want to introduce a Lord who shared
passion for the desti franchise and love
for the FBI genre that's truly shaped
one of the coolest members weather not
destiny community introducing the
community / production manager for the
Destiny community podcast and a twitch
murderer moderator for our very own
Bungie studio the folly mod of Destiny
and the man who generally finds himself
on the Abbate side of last word debates
you know I had to know that it laughs
from the DCP of making his debut into
the realm of the last word mommy
Lord Ares how we doing sir don't really
well man how are you how you been a
rough morning but uh better well we
definitely we definitely appreciate you
bacon and we know you weren't feeling
too well and to have you still come by
the campfire talk with us idiots about
the extra effort seriously - all jokes
aside but much appreciated about what's
going on in the in the community when
BCP and stuff like that you want to talk
just briefly you know just get started
out and stuff yeah just let people know
where you came from what you've been
doing in the desing community how you
got so ingrained to get the nickname
that you've gotten
explanation cuz they may not have quite
caught that one because even I didn't
yes sure so like I kind of gotten to
twitch with through what through watts I
watched a lot of her like YouTube stuff
nice like so and then I think it was a I
think was a video if she might have
posted saying something about twitch and
I was like oh I didn't know what that
was someone her friend she was streaming
at the time I was like oh this is pretty
cool she can like play the game and kind
of interact with people
mm-hmm and it's kind of went from there
[Laughter]
like you actually share some similar in
history to me as far as FPS so like halo
was one of the earlier games that you
started with right kind of same thing
for me I fell in love with that game oh
you could what now what now which halo -
real quick like which was the halo so
why not when I started playing online it
was halo 3 okay okay 3 and there now
prior to that you were you were with
halo 2 or so I hadn't played as much
halo before that I don't got you mhm
halo 3 came out with a new friends from
high school and all they're like check
this out check this out you were
evacuated into the Bungie ethos early
[Laughter]
you go from that and then like what did
it transform into did it transform like
to do the cards or anything like that or
yeah okay yeah so it was my war for two
at the time I can remember yes I'm just
kind of going from like the online from
Halo 2 online Call of Duty just kind of
learn and how that in-game works and
just kind of how smooth it is once you
kind of get used to playing it's great
something and then now to the magic
moment now destiny now were you there
I'm assuming you were there early for
like the alphas the beta that kind of
thing and if Ben what kind of drew you
and what was there the hook so so I
heard about like the game it's awful
bungees making another game cool that's
all it takes really but that's kind of a
start yeah so like I heard different
things
like oh you'll be able to like if
someone's heard stuff like that's not
even gonna be in the game from what I
can understand mmm Oh like if someone's
like like reading you you'll be able to
like pull your phone when you're do also
the stuff I've heard all of that kind of
stuff it's like wow that's interesting
but I mean that's not there but I just
think I'm interested and then when the
beta came out hopped in on the hunter I
just fell in love with all classes
representing today Fi this is good
so you just fell in love with that whole
universe the whole you know what all the
other things were the hook but besides
like specifically what was just like
seeing like a lot of the like the art
and stuff that had come out and then the
like the trailers and stuff it just
looked really good just they are sandbox
maybe they look beautiful
Oh Amelia check this out mm-hmm but me
would definitely I agree I don't eat
like for me it was the sandbox as well
like I remember just seeing that any
just in the music the music that's the
the O'Donnell day right so it's like
that August reheats
I'll be just at our screen hit you like
something's different happen in there
yeah so you got it to that stuff and
then you also are you doing sir how did
the whole thing transition I know you
said 5,000 with the hole for a DCP
correct right
yeah and you've been doing that for a
while stuff like that then you also
transition into twitch about moderator
for bungie like how did that happen yeah
so that's that was kind of with a poke
bear but bear was kind of facilitator so
some point we got to get him one here mm
go down guys don't talk yeah so so like
at the time on DCP where we're gonna
have some of the Bungie devs on so we
just kind of wanted to get some
background information on like like how
they would moderate for their stream
okay so we got advice from one of the
main guy that runs the Bundy channel so
we got them in contact with me to kind
of like if I wanted to ask questions
like hey
like what's kind of the route for this
that in the third okay cool and then
just I don't remember when it was but
when they when they streamed again after
that I went in to do my recent all for
the Bundy foundation and all that I was
like what is this order the ceremony
teaches up there with the sword and like
you put the sword on both shoulders that
would be amazing you're you're you're
now a Bungie mod indeed speak that'd be
amazing to be knighted by huge would
almost be as good as the Queen honestly
it's like that you just woke up if there
it was yeah how long have you been doing
it yeah um it's been quite a while now a
year or so this is the c2 journey I did
I mean for me that start story like that
that's like a little bitty true couldn't
you anything associated with Bungie
obviously you know my love for thee for
the studio and and their franchise is
but I have that connection I'm I'm
jealous that's that's awesome salute to
you there that is really cool you got
any questions what a special guest cuz I
could keep talking fixer mark there so
ok we gonna build I got questions no no
no my questions basically just when it
comes to the Holly Mudd name that you've
got there so and I was like I even I saw
you say that to us as we asked you a
couple questions and you said then
you're like Holly mod and I didn't even
put the Hollywood together so explain
where who dubbed you of that one it just
kind of how it happened I'm kind of
curious so like I to be honest I don't
fully know like who was like who only
goes in one person specifically but um
it stemmed from just like watching watts
for a while and then I became a mod for
her mm-hmm and that was like PD
days like back on the wrong PD yeah and
just watch PD a lot was around each oh
yeah and just around like the individual
streamers those around them so I started
minded for more people that were kind of
big in the community and then I think
when I played trials back in d1 with
Robby and Lou me like this Holly my big
we gotta get that more we gotta get it
out there so everybody knows how to call
you that when they jump in your twitch
stream what's up how you doing the joys
of moderation and in him but a most part
like you know would you say that you are
you surprised sometimes with some of the
things you come across that you have to
drop the ham on on is it yeah yeah yeah
it's like just some good example today
is just like people say the craziest
stuff in a stream that's about charity I
have fun yeah yeah yeah yeah yep
no I mean that's kind of one of those
the sad things too is just I was
watching I think maybe one of the first
bungee bunnies whichever one I caught
and people are just like asking about
this or asking about that and that's not
the whole point it's like yeah those are
things in the game they're dressing up
and stuff and they're that's their only
focus it's like why are we doing this
we're trying to do like the Direct
Relief and get all this these supplies
to the people that need them who are
basically on the front lines of
everything going on in the world right
now and then that's their only focus and
that's just when it comes back to guys
it's a video game look at the bigger
picture here like get out of your stupid
little box sometimes and it's yeah it's
sad it's sad but it's definitely
everyone who you're doing those
moderations for are very appreciative of
what you do because absolutely keeps
things in the proper direction which is
what they need
yeah absolutely yeah salute you because
at the end of the day it's like you know
I've been very vocal
obviously we destiny is a game with one
of these live service games it goes to
Peaks about there's gonna be times where
upset
stuff like that but one thing I've
always tried to stress is to be even if
you're not happy to be respectful right
to be and not be disrespectful in to
treat people with respect when you talk
to them and express and I know like I
said I have some people that moderate or
much down and stuff like that some of
the stuff you see it like really really
it has no place in this community and I
guess there's no keep up the good work
dropping them banhammer idiots positive
community that's very important
yeah the biggest thing that's like it's
it's simple like you can you can give
criticism or he could be an [ __ ]
there you go it's a saint you can say is
it different in two different ways fact
there's two different it's different
there's ways to go about voicing your
displeasure and then no personal attack
that's that's the other people sometimes
can't
don't be disagree without being
disrespectful and yeah well trust me we
in there are stuff Dan and luckily I
could tell me one time ever someone said
it something crazy oh yeah I mean [ __ ]
me for last word I think for long here
yeah maybe one time ever so we've been
pretty fortunate yeah yeah we're not
I'll say it's like it's one of those you
know you're getting bigger when there's
enough there's more crazy people or and
that's typically how that goes I was
like the one I wanted to ask you to is
you've moderated a lot of places and
this is not to do anything too specific
but it is when it comes to females who
game they have it they need probably
more moderators than anybody so when it
comes to like when you go between
somebody like you know bungee or anybody
else or even here and then you go jump
into like Miss 5000 watts like she's
like she seems like the chillest person
ever she's like ultra chill but just the
fact that like do you see when it comes
to female gamers like does she still get
like stuff that you don't see anywhere
else is that stigma still out there or
is it a question is it kind of still
yeah there's there's there's still a
little bit of it it's not it quite as
much he's good I feel like it used to be
okay I know she also has a bit more mods
at this point too so it's like okay she
gets a lot of help not easier to handle
yeah that's good yeah the only ones that
like for
me it's like even on my scale the ones
that come in that truly just come in to
say just nasty things but just yet like
out of nowhere it's like I can't ban
them I can't find the button fast enough
and it's just like I'm pretty reasonable
on most things in here all the
discussion with people everybody can
have their thoughts and things but it's
like if you just come in here and just
say like nasty things it's like I don't
even think I don't care if I like and
that's those the ones I wish I just
those waste your time if somebody's like
saying certain things or they just
coming in to me nasty it's annoying so
no believe me all the world of streamers
think the mods they you guys do a lot
more than people know guys the unsung
heroes for real always glad to help ya
Holly mud and yeah so if you guys do not
know areas as well definitely check him
out he's a new name to go by also if
you'd like to tell them what it is when
you're playing the PvP action he's got a
new name and it's called
air Aries carries so he's got some space
this man is tearing it up in PvP I've
jumped in a few backpacks bro you video
wall I need a little help we played a
little five week seven going on like we
played last night and I was just like
just for a little bit and I know
typically who's skill level I'm getting
into when it's out of my chest like oh
I'll play with my brother and he's like
dude you're tearing it up right now I'm
like I don't normally do this I jumped
in with Ares I'm like I'm on the bottom
of the barrel right now I'm just looking
up buddy come from my ego state like I
love play with some women was really so
much better right
well sometimes with Eagles protect like
I said you did do a man I know you guys
been banished up wait it's like like
it's like no I have citizen who's
attached at ease and he's one of those
guy like it's like when you finally get
what it's such an accomplishment that
you have warlike kills that it really
had
the Louvre it that that is awesome so
you'll be running pvp hard running now
you're still running trials in this
environment you still doing it going out
there so yeah I've been doing them I've
been doing some pieces do a little PCE
ok and what we've been yeah we've been
doing is uh when I play with riot I'll
like we'll try a little PC it's like two
three games in it's like alright these
people got some special name and I'm
glad you said that
Oh Gary I'm glad you said now I gotta
ask you because I see being you wanted
something stated thing now have you
jumped over the house the environment
for the tribes that ask the reason why I
jumped when a free trial is I'm like let
me see it put for trials because of
their environment it's long that it's
less of it so is it is it clean how's it
looking yeah it's really really good so
it's so I also think it the q mm-hmm
I've had the only issue of a fat one
issue with Q both in Charles and that
was Game seven
oh it's 30 seconds a minute
in a game nah all right that's what
about to ask because see my fear is when
I jumped on I pick up the free trial and
here's the so I I was like that to go
when I went to control mm-hmm that's so
they go for trials then so yeah so for
the most part I've been seeing more
trials and then I did do a couple people
couple control games recently okay I
wish I got into with someone else okay
it has the wait times on trials or match
I mean a minute oh hold on
sinister you had a chat brother big go
get that oh go give that stadium we're
doing this this weekend brother I'm
trying to get to the lab now and last
question and so competition now how is
it I mean well you're a god you're a
you're a PV people but for us lots of
mortals how how is it like over there
like you know is it is it is it really
you know like sweaty
is it are you are you facing competition
that you feel like you know what I can
hang
so there's so I'd say most of the time
it's people that can hang with or or
better okay it's it's it's kind of mix
it like because I have a few friends on
still in stadia and I know right it does
as well so it's one of things where it's
like oh like I can kind of see okay
there aren't trials will probably match
them time yeah they're they're easier
games mm-hmm
I think the other thing about it is the
if you use controller like I do I use
controller yeah oh he do it up my man
what's good see this is my brother
writer Aires is my brother you know what
time it is do you know what time it is
control the gang and we got the stadium
hustle secure controller and mouse and
keyboard there there are there as input
delay so that's something to get to get
a little used to yeah yes if you've
played on if you put it on it like a
decent-sized TV before and input it's
like that it's like that so it's the non
game mode big TV yeah kind of important
okay no refresh rate low free freshly
has then you have the console fov yes
cuz you take care - just fov right yeah
it's out
no cheaters no cheetahs though see
that's the thing is yeah I'm gonna say I
don't good they I mean it's basically
through their servers there's no way
they can get a hole a closed environment
brother
yes oh we got a sinister man we going
down you'll get that free trial y'all
we're gonna do a stadia trials run I
want to see how far I could get on my
car areas but if you're doing them dumb
stadia carries let me know me okay
brother this is telling me is that they
need dedicated servers for even just try
Lee yeah thanks yeah if they dedicated
servers for trials here we go like then
that would level many many things lag
which is annoying you're cheating and
garlic training yeah I was like then at
this black for them it's like which is
gonna cost you more pain to develop some
crazy anti cheat tool or is it gonna
cost more to rent some dedicated servers
like that max that could be honestly an
option so here's the technical question
e because excuse me because they're in
the steam and farm
and they even but I can understand on
well I guess it's it's their environment
first and then I just want know how that
relationship works with steam but I
don't imagine steams like exclusive I
mean are there steam dedicated servers I
mean I know something like Call of Duty
uses theirs but I mean even let's all
just Amazon Web Services whatever they
use like somebody's just good they gotta
get them from somewhere I would imagine
right yeah right and then but yeah
they've got a solid lead because again
the fact that like I say be it areas we
have to resort to other you know
specific platforms that have more of a
closed environment that's not doing as
much as the you know their stuff watch
play yeah man it's something that really
needs to happen I know we'll get into it
you know whether it be a true dedicated
I know they they have a Itachi in this
respect they do say they have it but
clearly you know the matches are not
working strong enough make it based on
what's going on like so on well I think
what happens to happen is like I think
like one of those will across there kind
of things or something that yeah scans
your PC well you have something
installed yeah yeah and now that's that
wall you know and I think and the last
last point I'm making I'll give it to
you guys is that um in my opinion I
think it's going on in the background
but I think it's conversation it's
probably more complicated that they have
to have between themselves and steam as
well because that's specific about for
me I was like so here's one of those
though you think about you saw Valerie
being played right now and I was
actually I forget who I was watching it
might have been layman possibly and they
were talking about just the level of
their cheating client it gets into the
kernel of the CPU and that's like a
level of innovation on your computer
that some people do not want to
authorize so I mean if you're getting
all the way that deep into the hardware
of your computer it's also if software
has access to that then people can
potentially obviously create something
to pay back off of that screw your
computer over so right there's a point
where again that's kind of the
development side of what's what people
want it's like and they also still had
like they banned 70,000 cheaters so they
if you still have something that deep in
there and people are they're still
having to ban that many people obviously
it's not working that well so it's like
so I mean
everywhere and that's kind of thing
about PC is like it's it's something
people can't deal with because it's just
an open it kind of comes with it yeah
it's it's one of those things but yeah
when you saw the 300,000 downloads of
that one cheat tool or whatever that one
kind of seems a little bit yeah it's
it's spooky man it's it's it's so sad
because they'd be we understand the
climate right we understand obviously
have a pen have it going on you know
they're not it's fully we get it you
know but it's one of those things that
it's almost like a fire alarm because if
they the numbers are look you got a guy
like me who's not playing I took a week
off right this uh this is rare feat
doing trials right my favorite thing I'm
a pvp guy it hurts my soul to not be
playing because it dad taught me my
favorite mode is back II can tell you
how much I've been on rent running
trials back obviously banner yeah yeah
you're better you know saying my one of
my favorite moles or pinnacles you know
you know it just got a you know what it
is here's my issue my dilemma is did he
indoctrinated me into PC fov every time
I give wallet credit right so it's hard
to go to current generation consoles
yeah 30 frames and no Appleby and yeah I
feel like I'm in molasses brother yeah
I'll tell you what I was playing last
night I was on PC play and then I jumped
over did a couple games on xbox with a
cool guy and everything for where for
today
he's a goodness I feel drunk you feel
like you're like yeah you're drunk like
so you're so slow moving in the
muttering oh and it don't get me wrong
4k HDR on Xbox series X Xbox one excuse
me yeah but um it's just you know it
looks great stating still but moving not
so much yeah like like shout out to my
boy for for said eBay like yeah
next-generation consoles can't come here
soon enough you know say but uh yes
WD Prescott I blame he he got me into
the VIP section of the club I don't want
to go do nothing less than VIP
like you've seen the champagne room and
now it is which you have that level but
yeah we see we'll see what happened but
I carries as sorry to catch you no nope
no I just wanted to ask Aires for we've
been kinda debating over it for a couple
weeks we have had different people on
and stuff like that but as you the the
scale of people that you've been playing
with trials in a lot of different places
I saw you helped out some people get to
the lighthouse and things of that nature
what are your thoughts in the state of
just trials right now between the
rewards and obviously we discussed the
cheaters but where do you feel trials
like how did it do in its launch and
what do you think it could do to either
get better be good bad vice versa just
it's like fair now kind of if we need
the tokens at all mm-hmm if like do we
need to get rid of the like the win
condition so like if you don't get the
three wins you can't turn into tokens
there's like a feel like and then the
flawless parts just like what's the
point
I feel like there's gotta be like a
nightfall type reward when you go for
something like that I have not adept
stuff all big-time celerity I'm sorry no
no I was gonna say I feel like you'd
like just the Adept I was like that's
such a I feel like that was a wiffle
ball miss like that was the LOB from
before that like celerity just like plug
it in intrinsically and that's like
people would have been happy with just
that that's it that would have been a
good start I agree cuz I even back in
the day of you know a depth for the most
part ii just had that they did have that
perk but i believe all the hair was like
snapshot intrinsically um it wasn't it
was something yeah it was something like
that
yeah it would be really like i think you
nailed it here today i wanna head as far
as the incense ares yeah definitely
needing those equivalent or even greater
than knife woolum yeah absolutely
yeah it's like UK if you put a team
together even the night falls can be
done pretty efficiently versus a 7 7 win
card between everything else that's
going on like those need to be
substantial and as pvp has been kind of
left in the gutter for a little while
for like new things and new activities
new stuff to do like this needed just
like hey it blows the doors off of
everything ok then go play PvP like you
needed to give a reason for people and
it's unfortunate where it's sitting
right now I like like a flawless reward
you know Minhaj oh you can go in and put
this here this here and get this about
something like that for that's dope for
flawless if you're flawless you get to
the chest but you get you have oh I put
this here I put this here I get a
shotgun and it could have whatever bonus
if you select you could take that even
farther to indentify flawless well you
could incentivize flawless and like the
more times you go flawless the more like
you unlock the ability to kind of
specialize in what you pick get like
master works like the range yeah like
you could take that another level and
how many more people are gonna want to
go flawless that way I'll do that
because I've heard people mention like
the sundial type pick at the end but I
like the I like the like the Menagerie
chalice type thing because you could
actually give that depth like the more
times you go you're kind of like
building awesome incentivising flawless
wise even tiles so I love what y'all
cooking right now I'm with this this is
really yeah yeah because this way you
have a room system you you get it by
going flawless which then encourages
that repetition to go all the way
instead of farming just the three wins
or whatever it is I agree with Aerys we
may have to do something about the three
win token caching system we may have to
do something about that
get rid of your guys get rid of tokens i
we all agreed them yeah
and just bring it back to bounties I
think if they do that those two things
in the short term they'll be okay with
the incentive aspect and then the
long-term obviously we know we have to
deal with the hacking and cheating stuff
yeah yeah yep and that's a bigger fix
for sure well yeah so trial is
definitely coming up this weekend Exodus
Blue is that the name of it is that this
weekend yeah yeah should be a fun one to
watch at least for sure there's so many
different lanes and play styles you can
do on that one between Snipes and a flow
so should be interesting to watch that
one what have you kognito been playing
in the world of destiny this week or
what have you been playing by the way I
wanted to ask you just kind of how much
destiny or not depending yeah but I'm
not embarrassed sir you know what it is
when you love a gay like best but you
don't play you feel like you're cheating
city-style wasn't play animal crossing
stop I'm Final Fantasy 7 is one of my
Mount Rushmore games there you go so you
know we got the Halos destinies all that
stuff but Final Fantasy 7 like I fell in
love with PlayStation one of the main
reason but thank you that in tech and um
when they heard about the remake I'm
like okay let me look into it and man
you know not only did they do a
phenomenal job graphically it's one of
the best looking games in a generation
I'll just get that out I've never seen a
game look as fantastic as it does it is
truly spectacular but that's the first
thing then you know it truly is more
than a traditional remake and I'm not
gonna spoil it is amazing the battle
system is outstanding you know II I'll
telling you offline you would enjoy it
because you know you come from the dark
souls room I'm not a Dark Souls cop guys
like I come by Megaman but Dark Souls
takes the difficulty but yeah yes three
spikes but like I'll be honest I'm
really not a fan of those games not
because they're not good gays is because
I know my tolerance level and all those
thoughts on control but I can't be there
honestly not for everybody they they're
not but like for those
who do play them they are pretty awesome
so yeah I get it
let me tell you why this why I wanted to
speak to you on this is because the this
game is the type of Dark Souls type
combat I like which is it's challenging
it's multi phases with certain bosses
with a lot of bosses but everything is
done with this cinematic animate Flair
between two people are talking it it's
like you're watching an anime and you
like yo but it gets you it could you
imagine facing a Dark Souls boss and
then why are getting into it he stops
and he's like okay Pontus let's see it's
like cheesy over-the-top like I don't
know if you guys I'm gonna show my age
right now but it's like back in the day
watching kung-fu flicks you know I'm
saying like those you know you'll come
forward okay it's dad so you got all
this stuff going on and in crab eautiful
things so again the nostalgic pieces for
the hardcore Final Fantasy 7 pure right
then you have this new game which is
like wow they take it in another
direction and I've been in doctrine so I
have my whole goal when I got it
released last week a half-finished it is
super challenging beat it finally this
morning took everything out of me to
beat that thing because I'm not a Dark
Souls kind of guys I was struck you know
saying but um it's really really good
shout out to dizzy in the chat loving
this Final Fantasy 7 talk so your Z job
he's a he's a power fancy six guys so
he's just mad right now no one cares
about his six and it's all about seven
right now it's all about the
gloriousness the coat final fantasy I
was gonna say if they ever remake if
they ever do a remit especially to this
level if they do for Final Fantasy 7
little trigger for Chrono Trigger though
yeah they're shutting down for me and
that is all in place
straight through understand it's like
this is my Chrono Trigger so it's like I
mean I'm in place I just beat it but
yeah I'll be good as far as destiny is
considered back on track
um I am gonna play on man I advised one
of my favorite moles I gotta get my
pinnacles together they don't say
and then home yeah not at the the trials
map is Exodus I'm definitely getting in
that and you don't put me on stadia game
and then areas what do you been playing
this week I've been doing some trying to
get all these for my bits I thought
unfortunately was not the person to get
oh yeah I got 5,000 I'll just turn all
these in a real quick yeah yes I did a
little bit of that on I oh I'm almost
done and then just am Iron Man
nice yeah what actually I finally got my
butt into pit of heresy so yeah I have
been working through that over the
course of kind of the weeks I beat it
solo yesterday word of advice to all of
you listening if you are working for the
solo triumph you can't let your game go
back to orbit you have to do the solo
still in one session I learned that the
hard way yeah cuz I did like I worked a
little bit on Tuesday I got through the
I'm trying to remember the Necropolis I
was like okay got through that saw the
ogres I was like that's late I'll just
go to bed and come back okay cool went
through the ogres and then I got to the
totem room that one took a while to
learn so it's like cool practice a
little bit went to bed worked on it some
more on Wednesday and I've been doing a
piece pieces over the day and then
finally it was like all right so Mac and
then it was just like I got a feel for
him had some stupid deaths and then
finally finished him up and I'm like
cool where's my triumph and I'm like
wait where's my triumph dude where's my
triumph or then I went to go jockey it
was not done no I was pissed so guess
what I gotta go do it again and after
after I do that cuz I doubt I will go
flawless the first time trying it again
unless I'm just ultra cautious that will
be my practice run for a flawless but
yeah if you are going for it even just
the solo you can't and go back to orbit
like if you got to go to the bathroom or
have some dinner keep moving that Mouse
move that character don't go to orbit or
you are gonna not get at the count which
that was like so you technically did it
but because of that Oh like nobody ever
liked hey I didn't like have my brother
start an instance to like reset me like
I did on shatter thrown one time
I was like hey I'm at this weird section
I kind of want to redo it alls like hey
can I jump into yours
I did and he left and then I jumped back
in and went through like the whole thing
and that didn't count before I was like
wasn't even that way nobody ever touched
my instance and I was just like so yeah
but I was like so now I've actually
spent a decent amount time in there and
practicing both of the fights so pretty
good comparison in between that and
shadow throw and actually now mmm so
between the two let's get it you know
what I gotta ask the question I was just
gonna say between the two there's
actually a lot of similarities because
you've got the Necropolis and Erebus
which are like cymbals roaming around in
different directions clearing out
certain things in a right order that
one's pretty similar then you have like
the descent versus the ogres and stuff
like that so you've got your weights
like like work through an area and kind
of stay safe and got some funky sections
then you've got your defense or
pain-in-the-butt like very small margin
of error section which is either the
totem for pit of heresy or
vork death I always get those wrong the
ogre in the shattered throne and then
the boss fight for both is patience not
getting greedy and don't have stupid
deaths like for both of them because
that's basically the way you can
describe both of those and you almost
like not to say they copy pasted there
they have a lot of differences but like
the theme of the fights actually kind of
hits pretty similarly so what's your
question I'm sorry shoots yeah not yet
my question is B question with Z wow
that's that's an epic yeah hold on let
me drink drink some of this focus
somebody can you guys clip this right
here sponsorship y'all get on that yeah
look at my man my man is out here anyway
[Laughter]
[Music]
we got a dramatic I respect you
hey I kick monsoon I actually was lucky
enough actually took one of my bags from
work and brought it home so I've
actually been told I see it is the work
but um question so in reference to
dungeon talk okay comparative you are
thus thus the night for soloistic
dungeon solo is I'm gonna give that
titled esoteric but anyways you got so
my question is you know now that you've
Dumbo you know head to head which is the
better personal favorite hmm see these
are tough cuz like I just literally said
they do have a lot of similarities I
would say I think pit is almost a little
more interesting it's like they took
everything and they refined it does that
make sense because they took we walking
around between the Erebus section with
the symbols on shattered throne and then
they added the fact that you have the
sword mechanics to kill the different
enemies going between the different
levels and stuff so that one was like
added on you've got then you've got okay
so I'm gonna go through like the slowed
section now I will say the one that like
when it cut there's not as much jumping
in this one like fer platforming that's
not as much there it's like no no no I
totally forgotten they do have the they
are almost dad similar because you have
the Hank the swinging Lantern section
with the Wizzle versus the cathedral
roofing well like that one and so but
they took each piece and they added so
like that was just like static and I
could sit there and be like pew pew the
ogre from far away now there's stuff
swinging I got to find different
direction so they basically took
everything you from shattered throne and
my brother I know would like it more
because it's not black and white so you
can actually yes yeah I like the red the
mattock yeah just the Scarlet so yeah
and they still have the equitable
phallic wall as well in their little
joke so I think overall I would say they
just they shadow throne was like kind of
like your first one so it's still really
cool but I still I think pit is probably
just really they just took everything
kind of refined
and just took everything up just a
little bit and overall I kind of like
the aesthetic of you know here's this
taken which guy versus here's a giant
fired night dude kind of just okay yeah
that's that EXO I'm gonna have to tip
the hat to pip hey this one yes so
pretty all right so I'm gonna dalla G
will be you know what you're coach at it
is the vault the glass if it is yet you
take a kick I'll show you the king's
fall that's your ring I was like yeah I
mean so far of the two I'm gonna put it
up there yeah it's gonna be no more
shattered self okay there's only two I'm
so it's one of two right still yeah it's
like no - it's like when you compare the
similarities and just the refinements
and the sword mechanics and I don't it
was cool so tough decision one thing and
I sat there and made the longest
speculation video I've ever made
the lite-brite wall which dates me as
well since I know you know what those
are
yeah four depending on how old you are
you may know or not but the lite-brite
wall moved this week hmm
so if you guys don't know in the IO
bunker and I can actually change the
background back now in the IO bunker
you've got some projections basically on
a wall showing hey this is where we're
at for the solar system this is like the
radar of Rasputin showing Sun all the
planets
couple of them aren't illuminated Kuiper
belt I learned more about astronomy this
week as well so apparently but yeah
you've got all these things kind of
showing where things are at and this
week the little orange triangles that
were to move to the left about eight
pixels and now there's eight ammonia so
there's all the speculation of like how
long is it going to take okay so I
photoshopped those like they moved
there's like what they were one ship
light now it's three ships wide all
right now it looks like okay so if they
move two ships per week everybody has
seen different angles on this one but
it's roughly going to get if they travel
at the same pace which of course you can
you know take that
the grain of salt until we see what
happens next week but if they travel at
the same pace they are going to get to
Saturn Titan Europa all that's or Saturn
and Titan at least at the end of the
season right so my light theory got a
good right there so that's like kind of
one question as to like what's coming
next season what's coming in fall as
well I've said all mine in a video so I
definitely want you guys to go first
because I've rambled about this a lot so
I wanted to get you guys thoughts of
both what you guys think is happening
next season and what you think is
happening in large expansion quote
wherever you want to call that September
October whenever that big piece that we
typically expect happens next so get it
yes sir
Aries you're first so I'm just kind of
thinking and I kind of like your the way
you kind of did the timeline of it but
um it's thinking I don't know how far
they'll go into the ships next season it
will kind of be like a like a little
little dip into it mm-hmm just kind of
show okay maybe maybe they've arrived by
Titan or whatever and they're kind of
there and you kind of maybe can interact
with it there but then yeah I feel like
the big expansion is gonna kind of pull
in it's kind of like okay we're finally
here that's what we're fighting do you
think in September okay so we get a
taste yeah so Season eleven you're
saying like the ships have like arrived
and then in the season 12 we're
interacting with whatever that's going
on yeah like I feel like maybe they'll
get even closer to actual Earth Oh at
that point isn't 12 Wow exciting stuff
so what else you what enemy I was gonna
say the other clarification cuz this can
change stories what is on the ships what
are we going to be facing like enemy
enemies yeah that's that's kind of the
question that's up in the air right now
is because you've seen all the or you've
heard I guess all the
it'll be this this race but yeah I'm
really wondering what they're gonna take
form of if you had to pick if you had to
pick a one what would you want to see
come September hmm definitely well I
guess I don't have a specific one but
just more of something that we haven't
seen before so not like oh well scorns
different something that's completely
you know many new models new enemies
incorrect the whole new mole new enemies
new abilities stuff like that yeah we're
definitely in need of enemy faction
refresh justice corn were cute but at
the end of the day we be you know a
definite fresh paint paint of enemy type
you know and I would love it seems so
ahead of schedule I'm struggling with
the areas a little bit because obviously
I was assuming my time I was assuming d3
we would get them but it does make sense
because you know with them separating
from Activision
you know I'm saying and you know we know
Activision it wants the hard and fast
rules every two three years a specific
time and Emmaus they may have said you
know what
you know 2020 we're not ready for a d3
or whatever it is and they may have said
to themselves we'll do it at all
well stretch this thing out and maybe be
arrival is kind of what you said you
know we'll get we'll get that in
September so um yeah I'm excited I'm
excited man I would love to see them set
this thing up right anyway we wrapped it
well one thing as much as we're
complaining about these in a worthy some
people are see them is that um I do love
tuning in to a rasputin bunker and
seeing space Doritos getting closer
that's got excited yeah okay so couple
things actually I'll get to my whole
crap here in a minute
Cognito you're no no you're up what do
you think what do you want eleven
seasons well yeah I gotta get you're
gonna get your speculations on record
yeah man I mean just pretty much
of what was said I mean you know what I
want is like I said last last word was
on Titan gotta go guys gotta go
I know no that'll actually like God yeah
I love you Sloane but you know we need
some glorious death going on we need
some destruction we need to feel the
weight of the space we need to know that
they are here they mean business and
there's nothing we can do to stop them
right so I love the whole angle of you
know powering up Rasputin because we
know it has to be more than just the
Almighty you know I'm saying so cuz
after that's done you know obviously we
see we still see the imminent threat and
yeah it would be like almost like you
know almost if they can do it like I
would in a perfect world what like a
doomsday counter you know that like that
yeah like oh hey common there's nothing
you can do almost like a terminator you
can't reason with it you can't be like a
minibike the world is gonna die from an
artillery and x-ray or like that's just
another Tuesday the states I've said the
style they need steaks they need genuine
fear that you know we haven't really had
anything since hey you know I'm saying
like we need some sadness right now we
really got it we got to do it I think
that's the perfect way and then let's be
real from a technical standpoint all
right from bunching like they said they
can't keep expanding this right yep so I
hope the director looks is tight and
like replaced by a pyramid could be
interactable pyramid just like planning
is just and then just live in this
governor this ominous sitting there on
your screen you know and dad dad you
gotta bring that tension that fear they
are coming you know so here's like no
don't keep going keep up no no that's
pretty much it just the whole I love the
conversation and you you highlight it
between Zavala and just work it out the
difference is we have to be a unified
front against this thing because they
you know well I want to jump in real
quick what if one that would have won
the directors scream they were able to
add just artwork of ships
let's get Marcus up a dead man that'd be
like yo we did a mock his prayer Bechet
let's hit a bond ship it'll be awesome
he's working on us right now that looks
pretty cool um which Ares I like that I
like that ik yeah I spent like an hour
talking to my brother and we went
through this side of things we went
through like thoughts of what could be
come in so first because I was saying
the same thing you are I was like couple
differences but it was like so tightened
could go and then he was like well what
about new light players and the og
campaign how do you actually go through
cuz Titans like second planet may be
your third like you go through the
campaign talk to us avala that whole
thing is not gonna be there and again I
know they are going to evolve the game
but you think hey you removed Titan you
have to change the rework of how the red
war campaign goes if somebody about the
red lake you know that stuff's free so
that's what I was wondering like if
Titan goes away how does that work
anyway I was like you threw that at me
and I was like what crap I don't know I
was away too like I wonder if there's a
way to like segment and in the sense of
new light you don't have this Titan
being gone yet yeah until you get to a
certain point in the story then that
would be nice actually if you can went
through the solar system kind of looked
normal and then when you finish the red
war campaign the light comes out and
then there's like this cinematic of a
ship coming in and Titans just lights
shut off or something like yeah that
would be a way to do it but then again
as you were saying cut you know it's
like that doesn't shrink the game any
that doesn't yeah oh this is my
suggestion I don't know if it could even
logistical II be done but my suggestion
is maybe they say to themselves okay
it's gone but like how we can still do
story missions with Kane right aids gone
right yeah but so maybe it is gone but
it's in like a story director thing or a
competent the strikes associated with
that still are there because yeah see
what you say the only here there's a lot
of question though there's Bisto and
it's quest that I I was like there's
quest for Titan you would live Sabbath
rune song for a strike
if you drop the planet now I don't think
you could get rid of the strike these
strikes I think I say that strike is
like for that planet if you're gonna
like potentially remove a planet for
quote growing game can't get to big
space then if you can access the strike
the planet assets per se in the game
aren't really gonna go that far yeah
that's C I don't know how that works on
the back end that's that's backend stuff
and you know I again in a perfect world
yes I would love Titan to go but there
are some stone making up some good
points there are some ling-ling
ling-ling threads that are connected and
how do they separate themselves by
getting rid of it but I do get a code
yes maguet écoles me this is this is but
a tech guys this is like your cabling
your wires all into crossed you know
saying ethernet cables all over the
place so Thor yeah this is on Titan
apparently so you really can't remember
yep I remember it is another exotic
quest that required you to go there it's
a setting weapons then would at least
allow you to get rid of how the period
Epson knocked out Titan at the same time
yeah yes II but we do it exotics that's
all so no this is like so this is what I
was wondering it's like my brother and I
talked through this a little bit and
Sabbath oon is gonna be like the wrench
I'm gonna throw in all this but I was
talking with him and I literally just
said the word he's not as much on the
lore like there's the world of by if we
all know who to what go watch for that
one but he's Sabbath who's a trickster
that's like her kind of title and name
and stuff like that and I said the word
trickster and it triggered in him he was
like what about the Marvel Loki story so
picture Avengers 1 Loki small like
picture a lieutenant and army given a
small army of ships Sabbath oon can come
in what does she want
well brother Lorex dreadknot right
that's what I'm picturing for September
is the same way they did the moon take a
remastered bigger dreadnought something
they already have somewhat built out
give it a reskin of some kind but also
give it more depth give it some lost
sectors it's an it's our destination as
opposed to potential leaks and stuff out
there but like a Europa that's like a
full fresh that's if you're gonna build
a whole new thing like everything's
brand new is supposed to dreadknots like
we got some spaces we can throw hey this
door open now there's a lost sector over
here at this doors open sector over here
I like that and you can SAP moons coming
in and then we can deal with Sabbath oon
and also the dreaming city which is
stuck in a loop because she's like cause
of that so I like that and that the
reason like that cuz we ended up talking
about that to basically say is like the
darkness is like Thanos like the veil is
that they knows bigger enemy and farther
away here's this small army you can be
of a little lieutenant go see how this
goes okay you're probably gonna get your
butt kicked betrayed or guardians we're
like Avengers so then we end up fighting
a Sabbath rune in the raid somewhere
related to the dread not to build a cool
raid in there dreaming city because of
Sabbath une somehow gets it's like three
week thing resolved maybe the 15th wish
is how we get to the Sabbath oon who
knows like all this stuff could actually
tie together using stuff from d1 and
assets we've got without having to build
like if you're gonna go an expansion and
like you know rumors are this thing is a
pretty good sized expansion like to new
destinations or something like that's a
lot of development it's time yeah a lot
and again this is like they're even more
so of a time when they haven't had help
for a while so even when they had
Activision's
other Studios before they could have
been working on like shadow keep and
other things now they are truly on their
own so yeah it sure my speculation and
I'll be curious to you know pick the
brain if somebody will mention to you
guys next week is basically the fact
that like Titan may be there or type may
be our base to fight the dread-nots but
the dreadmill switch right now it's
rotating around Saturn and the same time
like Titan is the moon of Saturn so like
as the ships get there maybe they're
going to the dread-nots to like set up
camp mMmmm so that's my
poor theory but it's I like it I like it
I like it a lot and I think you you
actually can it would tighten
specifically I think you can really
address both two stones you know send
because you can have you know the planet
redone in a destructive manner still
maintain the initial initial zones for
all you know request purposes and stuff
like that but have the new areas in show
from a aesthetic standpoint the
destruction of it going and he still
made you have the best of both worlds a
you you made a great point with the
dread-nots how it came in and I think
you can handle it in that kind of a fact
like a dreadknot fashion I think you
nailed it I think I like what you would
stone talk yeah so main the other reason
and this is where the big question lies
is if the main reason is if this is my
thought is because I'm still hoping for
that d3 we've talked about and that's
the main reason is if you go a pyramid
ships you have darkness rumors
speculation whatever else but like if
you have other darkness abilities and
stuff like that and if there's a light
and dark and anything of that nature if
they turn it into that you you I don't
it would take a crap ton of work I think
to put that into D to so that would be
the piece where d3 would do justice to
our pyramid ships I was even talking to
CB gray we've got to try and get on here
to I caught his twitch last night and he
said the exact same thing is like I just
want the pyramid ships to be done
justice and it's like a pyramid sorry
are eighties to bigger like the Sabbath
on pyramids are not like the veil I
think that might be like a way to be
like pulled a fast one on you guys but
you still got a big enemy here so it
would be a nice way to mess with
everybody learned like the scale of our
solar system small fact for you guys the
distance from the Sun to the earth is
one quote astronomical unit that's what
it's called literally whatever it's like
150 million kilometers some ridiculous
distance but Sun to earth is one
astronomical unit now the Sun to Neptune
which on our little projection board
that you guys can see if you're watching
the video that is 30 astronomical you
it's so it's a hell of a ways out there
and then the Kuiper belt that is next to
Neptune all the way out to there is 30
all the way out to 50 it is a like a
width of 20 astronomical units wide so
the distance from the earth to the Sun
multiplied that by 20 that's how big the
Kuiper belt is and they're outside of
that right now and they're outside of
that right you want to know the best
part so you know Pluto's not a planet
anymore it's called a centaur it's like
a dwarf whatever they're called there's
a couple of those out there
Nessus has got its weird ass orbit it's
really a funky orbit
Pluto's out there but the biggest one
that is that like 70 or 90 astronomical
units away you want to know what it's
called what it's called Eris really dead
serious and I was like are you guys come
on Bungie G's always good at that stuff
yeah it's called one of the biggest
centaurs past the Kuiper belt is called
Eris your er is spelled the exact same
that's crazy
that's crazy so I was like digging into
all of this astronomy stuff and I'm like
dammit Bungie so like I the whole the
object like the the unlit went past the
Kuiper belt that they're like flying
over right now yeah could be literally
flying past eros right now yeah I was
like so I was like I had to share that
one just cuz that's actually pretty cool
so that's pretty cool yeah real question
tea Prescott it's a question for the
host is the growing thought a location
is going it's because a location should
go or are we diagnosed diagnosing a
problem we don't know the full story
example just how much space they have
left well yeah I think what you guys
take well I looked up the size of the
game outside of PlayStation copying
that's needed for more size the install
is like 150 gigs so that's always a mess
but it's like it's 92 to about a hundred
and four gig between other consoles so
it's I mean it's large yeah I don't know
how to make the destinations and
cinematics and everything are but again
Call of Duty's the same size yeah so is
it like is removing Titan and adding one
destination that big of a thing because
if
go dig through my again talk to my
brother dig through the destiny
installation directory you can look up
like cinematics and audio and stuff and
those are of course so is gonna be the
biggest in file size they don't compress
very well so like is that destinations
like textures and framework and
everything is that the big thing or
what's actually taking up all the space
so we were actually wondering about that
and he was saying I don't know if it
really needs to go because that may not
be the biggest chunk right like that's
what Prescott saluted what you think
Aires
yeah I mean that's that's a good good
question like curious to see like how
much and at planet would take yeah
because like you just don't know but it
just seems like they're going that way
in terms of the story so know how close
do you know and be like you guys can get
this big and we don't know what that is
right it could be that - it could be a
current generational threshold right
there as on you know other platform
bellow you know PC or whatever it's not
it's not as much so yeah this a good
thing
it also also reminds me of d1 when you
know they were still holding on to the
Xbox 360 and the ps3 up you know because
they always had to think you always have
to think from a
lowest-common-denominator
standpoint because it's not just yes 4s
and Xbox one's not X's are out there so
exactly you know saying and that that's
one thing and I it is interesting
because in their mind then you say hey
current you know you could push it and
we always got to think about this past X
on it to our whole point which is what
we really want for d3 is next only I
want that to be a true next-gen game
because I mean oh yeah it's the it's the
whole concept of like the loading speed
we talked about it before but it's the
idea of like the game would be built
differently it's not like drive through
this corridor to the next zone and drive
through this Canyon for the next zone
it's like it's just open I'm like I
can't even like because we've been in
this type of generation for so long I
don't know if I can picture outside of
like Grand Theft Auto but like what a
true open destiny would feel like
because we've never haven't had it in
six years
use DP use ever
nvme SSDs going light you know let's
dude lighten speed brother let's do it
PlayStation the SSDs that go on the PS 5
literally don't exist you I didn't to
consumer pcs right now I'm just like
cool also crazy should be fine yeah I'll
be curious the system requirements for
d3 or like you must have an nvme as
that's the other thing too is like if
they build it for next-gen and it's like
they're literally about to say hey PC
guys your hard drive is too slow and I'm
gonna be like I'm sorry what literally
make like if they're almost skin at like
dumb I don't know that's what the one
thing I've wondered it's like both of
those are truly are on the nvme SSDs and
not a lot of PC's even go in via me they
go SSD which is still fast earth that's
the fact but not envy me like in
expecting that lock down bingo that
Bungie goes that specific because you
can't alienate so many people but I can
see SSD as a whole I mean that that all
you're just gonna be looking at loading
screens or something yeah we got to do
it stuff a game gonna be level different
generation gaming coming so yeah so that
kind of covers speculation of the lite
brite wall so we'll see what comes of
that next week will actually tell us a
lot to see how much they move if they're
moving at a steady pace or if they just
park for a while
honestly don't know out sanity has one
last question boy move on yeah of course
really when you have to ask yet do you
think Bungie to be working on a new
engine for d2 and use it for d3 I say no
I say they don't have enough two-bit
enough bandwidth and that it's gonna be
d3 only and d2 as he loves that I call
affectionately the the beat he was still
say those words I'd cover for me no I
don't worry buddy I could attack me I've
said so uh live team that's so much
nicer team it's cool it's fun thinking
about taking us up to Bungie and you
don't like that comment I just say you
know
I want to go I want to go but eventually
I like to call you so um yes III think
that they they're doing you know III
well what do you got to do out sanity
yeah and why do you matter yeah yeah
definitely I feel like the new engine
would make more sense with just d3 yeah
I feel like you'd be like it'd be too
much of a pain to try and transfer over
to a new engine as well as just build a
new game on a new framework just build
it from the ground up with a new engine
like yeah you can use data and like you
know all the values of some things if
anything carries forward but d3 new
engine I think you'd have to I think
you'd have to I don't know if you could
move an engine it's so far down in
programming not a programmer by the way
so could be completely wrong but I think
it's - it's what the game is built on I
don't think you could change that you
could make edits they do but I don't
think you could build it from the ground
up again well if you guys are watching
the video if you guys catch this on I do
try and find the YouTube versions of
this either on ebon TISS or iron Lords
podcast youtube channel but you'll
notice next to each one of us we have a
little emblem or a little class item
which is representing the of activity
that is coming up next week so we've got
the Guardian games kicking off next week
and everybody's gonna get their little
class item as you guys can see we all
have the gold version right now because
of course we all expect to win I should
change minds the bronze because I swear
Titans are just gonna lose but it is
probably gonna be probably gonna duke
out between the hunters and the warlocks
I think Titans I just hope we just get
comfortable wearing bronze
maybe not maybe maybe all the Titans are
just like alright guys let's show up and
band together buddy oh the Antaeus
Titans are gonna be there you go see ya
the in Titans are playing too much
crucible good it's all the crayons we
ate too many crayons he's fine but the
Guardian games is coming and it's a kind
of fun friendly class-based competition
so we've got Titans hunters and warlocks
kind of literally going at it for you
know top honors in The Guardian games
kind of the Guardian Olympics in the
tower and you've got basically a class
item for each class
Titans with their mark or luck with the
bond and then the hunter with their
cloak and they all have a metallic piece
to them and you're ranking throughout
the day is going to like each day it's
gonna update and how you update it how
you were the previous day for the points
you earned gold being first silver being
second obviously in bronze being third
but every day you log in you don't even
have to go to the tower to look you can
literally pull up your character and
it's gonna tell you right there so it's
gonna change every day knowing how far
you are into this thing we've also got a
couple things in the tower there's a
statue with a lion v is that what bird
is the Warlock one is it like an eagle
or what you think next type what this
bird has like whatever bird that is it's
gonna be grand looking wingspan so
whatever warlock bird it is and then the
hunter with the snake and there's a
statue and it says every day that statue
is gonna kind of update like which one's
the gold part of the statue and the
other two are just kind of stone as
who's in first and the idea behind that
statue look is that statue is going to
stay in the tower post guardian Games
and the only one that's going to be gold
is the top dog winter so it's gonna show
whoever actually like wins the whole
games and then the other piece your
class items wherever you finish if
Titans are third at the end of this
thing my Titan mark is going to be
bronze indefinitely
interesting yeah oh yeah yep yep for the
rest then they say the rest of the year
I'm guessing assuming the rest of the
Bungie or the the rest of the Destiny
year so through like you know if all
expansion with me I guess but yeah so
depending on what color you want or if
you're like hey hunters are the best and
like a warlock walks up with the gold
bond and they're like and check the
scoreboard it's gonna be it's gonna be
interesting for bragging rights so I
kind of want to get you guys thoughts on
that before we kind of jump into what
you'll be doing for it just the kind of
foreverness of some of these and kind of
the way it's getting updated and stuff
like that so like overall like the idea
just kind of that's nothing could feel
like that's something that we've kind of
talked about for a while
listed in the community just like hey
let's get like a like a community event
involved like that and for all the
classes
I really really liked all of the design
I'm I like all the designs of all the
different class coffee items and it's so
clean the other thing I was gonna kind
of bring up before we were talking was
uh just the live game you know like
shout out shout at the money for the
live game just being able to update
stuff like that on a daily basis being
able to show who's top dog like that's
awesome
that's impressive tomatoes we could give
credit eat you know we know what's going
on we know the bad thing you know have
fun let's be real
oh you know for fans of destiny we've
been doing this internally amongst
ourselves anyway right because we all
yeah love our class we love what we mean
you know it's a feel-good kind of fun
thing you know and I shout out to those
guys for maintaining you know the whole
daily you know competition aspect you
know who's winning stuff and I love the
touch of the the colors changed and
stuff like that and let's be real like
and I said it before Bungie does well
when there's good reward incentive right
you look at that outfit we talked about
this before II talking about pinnacle
game content and this is a little bit of
a mistake we thought what the Grand
Master anything if you put something
like this as a room war look how excited
we get we like you I gotta get that
cloak I gotta get this thing you don't
say like that's what makes people going
that that's I just want them to look at
stuff like this and I buy that back the
pinnacle because sometimes we feel task
it's a little too much love lately you
know we love - yeah but you know we
we've been shopping at your boutique a
lot now and it's time to put this back
into the game and I think someone had it
on reddit and it was a great point again
this is not bungee attack session but
it's just one of those things where it's
like you know sometimes you lose sight
that our clothing ornaments our loot the
in a sensitive or Lou they're incentive
so you don't necessarily have to put
guns in a roll and all that you but
these type of cool designs and
aesthetics to it in ornaments mhm the
player base comes flocking will be
running them grandmasters huh with
running nose all these night balls but
these kind of things because people want
that visual representation of difficult
content it's a it's a sign of honor it's
a badge like yo so Ace of Spades or in a
minute
Charles I'll pre primate trials you know
how you even nailed it even further
hmm could remember they Eve again even
when you go to test now outbreak primal
that stuff has trial stuff that you can
buy exactly take that could you people
some of that stuff needs earn it like I
just got done doing pit of heresy there
should be something from there that I
can bro air like hey it's a crazy ass
crown or yes you should be looking like
Sabbath boon when you came out well
Little Mac like it how I could do it
were in the fire Knights head and like
yeah you look like you look ridiculous
right now how do I get that late yeah it
sounds like I solo flawless the I've
solo flawless that I got it and you can
even get it as an ornament that's this
is my worry about these is it so you
have to wear it which we'll get to in a
second to actually make your progress on
said event now there are class I don't
have stats as much but you also still
have an infinity you got a pic if you
level it up then it's gonna be expensive
to change the affinity I would like them
to give us one of these whatever you
know the winner like if Titans are gold
warlocks or silver and hunters are gold
I said hunters and Titans are bronze
sorry that's just probably gonna happen
but it's like somewhere to go pick up
like even if Ava leaves go to say the
fall and be like hey go pick up your
ornament for your class item and you
could always put that ornament on there
and be like hey this is my Guardian
games ornaments like I want an ornament
of these if there's not one I'm worried
you know it's like whether it's two
seasons later not gonna use it anymore
and I would love to be able to have that
represent
as least as long as these d two's alive
of like hey we got third
hey we got first like give me I want an
ornament of this one I'm done and if
it's not I'm gonna be kind of sad no
completely agree you know you should
have that but do a pit you know I mean
definitely big-time yeah and then
Prescott set it to its like the ship and
sparrow this season the ones that
literally look like they're from the pit
of sorrow sorrow why either in the ever
verse both of them one I'll take one we
could take come on
yeah we've gotta fix that easy cuz you
do that look how exciting was bridges
they operate cool ones there oh yeah
those now it was like in their defense
they did say like the ornaments they
sold for whisper paid for zero hour
right they have said that previously but
it's also but it's like hey it's one of
those comin or coming yeah there's a
difference between you know having an in
man we understand to pay for future
stuff we respect that but you got to
have balance right you can't have
nothing in the opposite side it has to
be right now the scale is just way too
fast
and not enough you know game rewarded
again and they always seem to be able to
make seasonal armor for Guardian games
and then there's there's the Guardian
games armor and the gardens The Guardian
games ever verse Arbor like there's
always another set in there like there
should be at least a couple more of
these some other places so yeah I think
we all agree on that one pretty easily
yeah yeah but as for the games itself
we've got a couple things related to it
with regards to the event so we talked
about kind of the tower with the statue
the little that's gonna kind of update
and stay permanent when it's done but
they're also Flags actually in the tower
that have kind of a height to them and
they say the way it's read if I can find
the thing about the flags that they
actually update almost life like
throughout the day they state that the
flag is actually update throughout the
day so what those are like you know you
log in at noon you know and there's like
the Warlocks way up here the tightenin
hunter pretty close and all of a sudden
like the hunters creeping up you're like
oh crap we got to keep going there so
like those actually seem pretty cool
that they might actually be updating if
they're really going live throughout the
day with the flags I will be very
curious to see how that
goes because we've never had any live
representation even in before for the
for the light not the lighthouse but
making the lighthouse the empyrion
restoration there was still not too much
in the game I guess there was the little
hologram thing that kept updated so yes
that did but I feel like they almost had
like buns you had to like kind of they
would tweet it out and I don't know if
they did it or the game new but like to
if it's the more live stuff that we can
actually see I'll be very curious to see
how that goes but mmm those flags
updating life seem pretty cool and then
of course we know there's an ever verse
sparrow in there says there are two new
ships and sparrows parked at the
warehouse so you can go buy a reverse
and get those the sparrow actually looks
kind of cool I'll be honest that one
actually doesn't look too shabby we've
got a if you finish the weekly on your
laurels quest you unlock a Bungie
rewards Guardian games box which looks
like it has a I'm gonna call it a pin it
basically it's a little triangular a
little mini flag one for each class it
looks like a postcard I think it's a
towel it looks like a towel underneath
the postcard and then also kind of a
pretty cool looking Guardian games
almost Olympic looking pin so if you've
basically finished the weekly quest
you're gonna be able to basically go get
yourself a Guardian games box take that
stuff home with you but the way it's
gonna work is players can pick up medals
from Eva and complete them turning in
medals in the tower podium will increase
your team's daily score pick up Laura
these are the ones that are confusing
here the laurels pick up laurels dropped
by other players during Guardian games
to complete medals and advance your
team's rankings laurels will drop in
activities except gambit and crucible
where there will be awarded after a
match and I'm trying to figure out why
are they gonna drop is it like if your
buddy dies in the infinite forest or
something yeah I haven't quite
understood how they're dropping if you
just like hang out next to a buddy in
the tower and he's just sitting there
dunking like I don't know but you also
gonna earn those from gaming and
crucible games so if you are spending
the whole week into trials you're still
not wasting your time which is good and
then you've also got three exotic ghosts
so it says complete Evo's weekly exotic
quest to
one of three exotic coasts complete all
three weekly quests who gain all three I
don't know if you've seen pictures of
these things yeah yeah oh they are
awesome bye yeah so they've got probably
the coolest looking ghosts I've seen to
be honest with you
the Warlock want I'm gonna say you guys
kind of win this one whoa it's a giant
gold bird it does kind of cool a snake
for the hunter and then the Red Lion
looks pretty cool but the gold bird is
just like yeah I'm awesome up here yeah
I need that over warlock right there
have a whole Osiris the big weight
weight to my outfit you gonna see the
outfit when I do it
shada go me but I will I will say we
just got done talking about earnable
stuff you can actually earn an exotic
ghost for a change things like okay
little by little and now the big
question is are the perks on the ghost
gonna suck cause if guiding light's not
on I'm never gonna wear it which is the
problem guiding light has to be on there
I need I need the speed one yeah yeah
that's the lunar shell cuz also the nice
thing about the lunar shell that you got
with shadow key whenever you pull it
from collections it's a combo detector
for whatever like a random roll on a
plane it so I literally just have seven
or eight of those between all my
characters and I need nothing else
now the lunar show you had to buy so I
don't know if you have it or not but I
got that was that was the shelter that I
got it from I got it from Everest
sexually
hmm I got a check but yeah that like
these exotic ghosts
I hope the perks are right otherwise
just gonna be a little annoying but at
least you can earn them so I'll give
them that very cool I did want to ask
you guys though is it says players can
pick up medals from Ava and complete
them turning in medals to the tower
podium will increase your daily score so
one does sound like we've got more
bounties which some people are getting
tired of the whole bounty thing yeah but
the other side you have to turn them
into the tower podium so you can't even
like finish it and just like click on it
and get the credit for your character
you got a flight back to the tower go to
the podium and turn it in there
so it's just kind of curious you guys
thoughts both on the fact that it's like
here's the other thing because I got a
little couple vital information
Ava's daily reward packages will only be
available to players who participate in
that day's competition by depositing at
least one medal daily reward packages do
not stack ava holds at most one package
at a time so I don't know how this is
gonna be is it pick up one go to a thing
back to the tower one thing back to the
tower one thing and I'm honestly just
thinking I'm really sorry for consoles
right now because those loading times
before our laying that sounds painful
so just kind of curious a guy's thoughts
about the 4-1 potentially more bounties
and to the fact that it might be like a
one-and-done back-and-forth thing that
could be reading it wrong it's possible
what you think so I guess for me it's if
it is it sounds bounty asked if it's if
it's oh go and get kills with a sword
sword come on
I'm not interested if it's hey let go
like good a crucible and kill like like
you know some of the crystal wants so if
you kill like like a warlock it's like
five or yes or something like that yeah
stuff like that can get you going cific
yeah different types of content not just
use specific weapons that you may or may
not want to use yeah I'm a little bit
better watching you mm-hmm like how do i
abandon thing people at a certain
schools yeah i could actually think of a
funny one go do vanguard strikes and get
the most kills in the strike can't
actually slack you actually gotta get in
there and kill as much as possible go do
gambit and dunk the most moats or do the
most boss damage or any gambit i'm i
don't know much today but he's like cut
today but she just removes the sword
from you it's although it said i mean
that's fair but yeah it's like if they
do as you said it's like if it's get 50
kills with an auto rifle and strikes i'm
gonna be like but as you said if there's
cool ways to make it
competitive like you know get to the end
and be like hey I had the most kills in
a strike I played with two blueberries
cool awesome done or you played with
three people on your team and you're
like okay guys it's on yeah it's all
baby I'm digging out standouts and he
made a great point I will one of the
positives of the rasputin bunker
bounties is the or qualifying so it's
like it doesn't lock you in like if
you're a PvP guy because someone about
my oh this is easier people or something
like you know I'm saying oh but like for
the PvE guys they like oh man I don't
want to go but I could kill all I was
killed his effects major and I know it's
trying to do it in that is a great point
I was standing Lda they I love the or
qualifier good to you Ares you like that
a lot yeah big-time they're learning the
bounties are evolving we're on this like
six months six month learning cycle it
seems for basically everything in the
game so hey how did season of the
undying go well whatever they learned
from there had a chance to make it into
this what they learned from Dawn is
probably gonna maybe get into next
season but most likely Dawn's gonna
probably go into the fall so again we
have feedback and they're like we
committed to our decisions on this stuff
like six months ago guys we can't change
it like six weeks before launches we're
like refining and testing and stuff so
again feedback and that's one of the
things they've talked about in the table
to feedback takes time but like we're
seeing these type of refinements slowly
trickle in in places and I think the way
you guys describe the medals for this
one man I'm hoping some of these come
true because those honestly sound
awesome yeah what if in crucible like go
play and Rumble and you've got to get
top three or you go on strikes and kill
the most enemy it's like a way to have a
chance to do both I like so many cool
ways this could go cross our fingers I
guess that they work that way and we've
got one more thing related to Guardian
games the heir apparents the exotic
heavy machine gun so if you guys have
seen the little trailer there is one out
there go look it up it's got a little
clip of it actually firing there has
been some data mining and leaks from
this thing so everybody seemed to assume
this is where it was coming from they
were correct yeah I wanted to get you
guys thoughts is it seems to be
not overly difficult to earn it seems
like it's gonna cover in this one that
we don't know all the steps exactly but
it is going to be coming from Guardian
games do you guys think it's gonna be
hey you have to do 9 of 10 triumphs to
get this thing or how do you guys expect
us to have to go through this thing or
do you expect any type of actual quests
or just like check a bunch of boxes it's
kind of curious a guy's thoughts before
we get into the gun itself mmm I'm open
I'm open there's a little bit of a quest
for it hope it's just not like Oh or
that or like if you turn in a certain
number of medals or something like that
maybe even unlock something for it
well you buy like what was it by the vow
with so many like her tokens or one of
those things were called like enough of
said activity like you can actually buy
in yeah I agree I agree it incentivizes
continued to play the in event and then
you have an ascent amount and then
unlock I'm cool but I mean don't get me
wrong pretty to question like do enough
to unlock the quest like you have to
start the quest by getting a certain
point I don't know but I was like so the
gun itself is a heavy machine gun seems
to be arc seems to fire pretty quick and
pretty steady in the video as well the
stability on sweet business s yeah it's
like so yes I think I don't know why I
thought it looked like it might have
been the heavy arc any any special perk
did it perfect if anybody revealed that
yet not officially revealed if you would
like me going yes let's go the
unofficial word about this is the fact
that you have to spin it up before you
can fire it so kind of like sweet
business it's got to get up and deciding
sweet business fires slower but it's
room a gun for it's a fire functionally
in real life has to be at full speed
like rotation so then it has the spin up
and then you could like have it spun up
and then like fire when needed but the
other piece is if you spin up at full
health it's potentially got an arc
shield is the Loom okay little defensive
action yeah so seems pretty cool if
nothing else it does look awesome I'll
give it that the gun looks very very
good like the aesthetic especially and
I'm wondering if the picture because
everything we saw in game before it was
all very gray when we saw the trailer
preview the picture in The Guardian
games page has like it's a little more
silver kind of like polished a little
bit of gold
accents on it it looks a little cooler
than it did before so I'm not entirely
sure how it's gonna look but it looks
pretty sweet I like it I like the way
look I've always you know the Cabal
weapons I like that we sometimes we get
exotics based on the weapons enemy you
know like Queens breakers brawlers in
that'd be no no this is something that
those mini guns you know cabal have been
terrorizing us Mattel's
oh wow they rev up you know so it's cool
to get their weapons
I'm confident nice excited a little bit
man it could be fun start up on Tuesday
yeah so next thing we've got that is
actually ongoing right now if you guys
don't have it you can't actually get the
Guardians hearts emblem if you guys
haven't seen that one out there but it's
a very cool looking in bloom I kind of
like the I don't want to say crayon look
but actually they did a really cool way
to make it look I mean that in a cool
way because that actually does like it
has a very artistic look to it like it's
not done and like here's this very
computer thing it looks like it's like
hand-drawn and so you've got the
guardians heart emblem and you get that
for any donation of $20 or more and all
of this is going to the direct relief
which is basically supplies for all the
people in the frontline fighting the
virus out there right now and as of
writing the article they said they'd be
terminated over 450,000 dollars that was
as of yesterday and I'm checking right
now and it said 556 yes 556 thousand no
you're good let's you beat me to it but
that's totally it's all I was gonna say
is their goal is 700,000 of course top
donation by the way got a shout out the
man Pete Parsons donating woven $7,000
oh he did it in the first hour like I
saw like they were gonna like fight
there was said like I was like oh two
three four or five thousand I went to
like twelve thousand I was like what
happened and it was like Pete Parsons
popped up with seven I was like there
you go sir top man yep CEO money thrown
it around but I mean he's got to have
some change in his pocket so he's like
here but of course in proper bungee
style with seven but this is cool and so
if you got 20 bucks if you guys trust me
times are not easy right now so it's not
good easy to ask for anything but if you
can
this is directly again going to all the
people who it's medical supplies all
those things for people who are
basically on the front lines of this per
se and it's just going straight to them
so if you can spare the twenty bucks
gets you a cool emblem very very good
cause I wanted to shout that Aries just
salute there you just put that at the
link in there it is yep don't forget for
those who don't know who want to who
want to contribute you know who can
please do it it's for a great cause
Brannon yeah you know we're all going
through this thing together so it's
always cool and again we gotta give
punch they usually very on top of
current world situations you know yeah
and this is again another reason why we
love this community so much always
thinking about I mean they did the Nepal
one a while ago I still have that shirt
they've done the Australian wildfires
yeah they've done the iPads for Kids
program as well so I mean they've got so
many cool they're just a nice company
it's hard dude that's why they're like
literally my favorite developer I'm
saying in my top five they always
regardless to how you feel like they
always it's not it's something special
about domestic it just it just is it
it's not I'm not trying to family I've
never been a come around a community
like it's you know when you do the the
st. Jude stuff and all these things that
continue to support each other
it's one of the very best communities
absolutely so when you go in there by
the way when you go in and go in and if
you want to get to the emblem make sure
you select it as well as a reward and I
think there might even still be a pole
Oh like who is the bravest class I think
it's still there then and then they take
they said it takes like a week around a
week or so sometimes it's a day but um
go to your email just check in like
promotions and check in junk mail make
sure it's not in there oh well on it yep
si Aires doing the work out here
part of that bungee family they're got
mine absolutely yeah the information now
one of the thing I did kind of want to
mention
is the pre the pre table tweets that we
have seen a couple times the past couple
of weeks from Dylan so basically what he
said is he has been honestly setting
expectations before the twelve actually
even comes out and he's done it a couple
times now I'm trying to find the
previous one this weekend last week he's
actually just said setting expectations
this is what we're working on and I'm
trying to find that tweet right now okay
so here's the example gives a few short
notes and this kind of leads into where
the table actually wraps up so setting
expectations week two we will have a
timeline for incoming maintenance
required for two point eight point one
ELISA bug fixes in a preview for
upcoming seasonal event we're still
working on plans for various feedback
items that you've had some have
short-term mitigation strategies being
proposed while others require long term
systemic changes have a meeting at one
to go over a few topics but more
conversations need to take place before
we can commit to specific plans one
sustainability is the plan something we
can support in the near term but also
over the course of a year of destiny to
impact what items and development could
handle the shift in resources again
people are doing other stuff so to fix
some things moles people from others and
put that link Wheatland yep
so three the solve does the plan address
the issues at hand or will a proposal
only address a portion of the problem
space and unknowns what other issues
could arise from the problem that will
then need to be prioritized
it's a tricky dance and we want to get
things right and that's again probably
something we've mentioned here before I
know it's like if you can empathize with
what they're going through it's not just
like they flip a switch and stuff gets
turned on or instant fixes in any way so
the bottom of the table can Dove
reiterates this I want to read this one
and then I'll shut up for a minute you
go for okay so we come to a close on
another tois but we understand there are
some topics that weren't covered on here
that you may have a strong desire to
know more about ever verse literally
talked about it trials improvements are
planed to address FOMO tackling the
pounding problems and more there are
also questions like what about feeling
like players can't play their way what
about ritual
it's anti-cheat improvements etc we've
been having frequent sinks to talk about
these issues and more many of them
require a long-term plan of the
short-term mitigation to help ease the
pain the last thing we want to do is
over commit to changes that ultimately
may be reversed or sign the team up for
work that leads to crunch again they're
very good about taking care that Felda
purse they want to avoid crunch like
everything because they did that in the
holidays and they don't want to do it
again we don't want to make promises we
know we can't keep so to speak over the
next few weeks we'll hope to solidify
some plans and get them communicated out
we're looking at what can be
accomplished in season 11 which is
coming mus faster than any of some of us
can believe some topics will be tackled
in season 12 literally the first mention
of season 12 as they require larger
scale systemic changes thank you
everyone who's been giving feedback over
the over on destiny over the years this
train never stops and we hope to share
our next steps with you soon until next
time we'll see out there in the wild so
hmm I wanted to get for one I mean areas
you can kick off first because they
don't even got a pretty good you know
pulse on what's kind of going on out
there just if you want to either fill
people in the thoughts on this one also
just kind of your thoughts on what you
know the understanding but also things
that you're like you know kind of do
want to see yeah yeah I mean I'll say
the biggest things that I kinda want to
see are the like the error coding in the
crashes like that feel like that's been
haunting way too many people it seemed
like I guess they'd fixed something with
a tower they did a tweet with yeah
artists they did it tweet the beetle
errors in the tower they reduced number
of people in the tower from 26 to 12 it
seems to reduce errors for beetles we
had just stuff like that the cheating
then just or the anti cheat as a whole
mm-hmm
kind of just somehow get that addressed
that's like the biggest thing for me I
feel like and then just trials bringing
there's too much I know I
I've been much in the Final Fantasy yeah
I missed this and this is lit it's
important you know I mean we you know we
understand a situation
but at the same time communication and
transparency II - quelling the angry mob
like me so I've been angry you know and
at the end of the day you know I think
this is important they're explaining why
these decisions you know take time and
we do understand that like he's saying
it you know if you do one thing is it
really solving the issue or is it a
banding effect right we get that you
know saying the only counter I have
everything he said it's factual as
parent and important the only counter I
have - one of the things is with regards
to the anti-cheat stuff is because the
problem with that when you have that
kind of thing running rampant you now
kill your population when you guys got
guys like me not playing we got a
problem because I'm in that middle zone
I'm like I'm hardcore
you know I'm saying but also I do casual
eyes it every once in a while and the
thing is if we are not playing then your
population goes down people not gonna
want to come back so that the thing
about it is that has to be pushed up and
I believe on who put it up I'll shout to
uh low no again he had a fantastic thing
going on right now he actually interview
you know they actually interview about
him right he I believe I work with
someone who arm was actually
manipulating in chief and the problem I
had which was scary was the east of
youth they have no fear
they're running rampant and when you
have that skewing up the integrity of
your game that now has to get shot up so
he make child to damage right he made a
point they may have to look at saying
look we have the three team right
team one working on destiny three team
to potentially working on matter in new
IP team three which I won't say the
bangs you'll get mad he's always working
on you know the current live game so
what I would say is you may have to
reallocate resources for this issue
specifically because if it kills your
integrity of your game people are not
want to stay around and it's flush
straight you know I'm saying so that to
me has to take precedence and if they
can do that obviously whatever you
saying beaver I mean we can't have
beavers run around to be animals running
loose yeah they get integrity of the
game stuff has to be priority if your
game is broken and does not work you
know saying people are gonna knock stay
here so that we got to get that done and
shot the fourth set a year the righty
vid was interesting yet depressing at
the same time these guys are really
running around like it's the wild wild
west they have no fear of being arrested
they have no fear of of getting caught
we can't we can't have it so that's
that's my hope with this but this is
dankey for bringing this up because I
didn't know damage and these guys made a
response and I like that there's just
less hopefully they can take some real
aggressive action on that one yeah
and that's a hard thing to for them
because I mean picture like what other
to a sense of like when you're saying
pulling resources off of another team
like pulling artists and other things
they're not gonna help like network
security so it's like that team is still
mostly gonna be the ones responsible for
this I'm not saying like hey you got to
go crunch and pull in overtime or
something like that but it's like the
team that's working on this is not like
magically hey we got 12 more people well
I'm a game tester and I'm an art guy
what can I do in their legs nothing get
out of here you're not gonna again it's
hard for them to say this is an easy fix
but also it's like if there are 300,000
people downloading and it's like you
guys need to download it and kind of
reverse engineer which obviously easier
said than done but elation to some
somebody needs to be out there like
trying to figure out all the ways
hackers are getting in and trying to get
the same program so they can hope you
work against them which I'm sure they're
doing what is this has to come from the
top though he like yeah
this you know shout-out to Pete shoutout
to Luke Smith shout out to mark
Noseworthy you know this this directive
has to come from the top to prioritize
it's like an organizational chart I to
come right we know they have their set
plan we know that there's a timeline
each thing and we know their specific
resources involved I don't know which
one
I'm not saying which one to suffer
whether it be d3 or matter the new
eyepiece potentially but one of those we
gotta pull like you said he just dose
whether it be that the network security
guy the the technical engineer whoever
is on those two if we could just borrow
those reasonable if it's that simple I
don't know if it that's it by I could be
oversimplifying but if you know we we
literally have to resource manage this
right now because it's bad man like I
got my boy sinister here we got some
hardcore guys and I get it you know the
glad stuff like that but you know when
you got that what I consider you know
the the middle popular because I feel
like the glads and those guys I consider
those guys like the 5% no disrespect
they those guys are amazing but they you
know they've run through content they're
expert level we're doing this stuff but
then you got guys like me who go at like
a moderate to some I aggressively the
bigger population I feel that's the in
conjunction with the casual so when
we're not playing the casuals look to us
like hey is it good is this is it safe
to put your put in you know and if we're
saying nah man
you know you maybe wanna take a break
you know that's not good it's not
overall player health overall player
population goes down so what we'll see
we'll see what we'll see what happens
hopefully yeah it's kind of the only bad
thing about having your ear to the
ground as well is because even yesterday
I was actually playing with Forte just a
little bit in iron banner Oslo and there
was there was a guy sniping and I know
there are good snipers I'm not gonna
argue there are some people who take a
joke snapshots one was that and but
literally legs whilst sliding down an
insanely long hallway still picks me and
I'm like I know those are gonna be done
but I was like he would get like Bam Bam
to Dublin I'm layin areas like there's
like you could probably look at and be
like yeah that's a shot I've made and
I'd be like old and holy hell you're
just so much better than me but it's
like yeah well he's like and I know they
are so much better I was like I'm so
mediocre at PvP especially when I jump
in like your lobbies areas I'm like you
this skill good
I'll just look it up the whole time like
man it looks bad for down here but when
I question it and I really haven't done
that as much before to say hey that
guy's just damn good impressive shot I
was like yeah did he make that shot or
you and I and I hate that my mind even
like things thanks guys just because
it's so a parent out there right now and
apparently easy to get to and I was like
would you really do it an iron banner
and then like you know then you're gonna
go pull up your destiny tracker and see
what their Katie's like and stuff like
that and it's just like what oh I mean
Aries ran into one of the best ones that
it was you and was it you yeah yeah I
mean equal guy and you know what you
guys ready to talk this man over here
rockin uh it was on what does court its
men 99% revoke or headshot occurs when
you died you could see him like so if
I'm like if someone's over here and I'm
on this side of the map yeah if he dies
he would like as soon as he would not he
could you could see the person that
killed you yeah he would you could see
the person like like looking towards me
through Wow so what would you like run
up and die so your body's like able to
look at him and then you can like watch
him track you basically you can yeah
yeah he could see yeah so you're like
we're behind a building you're like he
knows exactly where you are like yep
it's basically it's just boxes they see
a box and it says oh there are so and so
yeah because that's the thing like what
I was playing and I'm like I hate you
said it perfect perfect you hate that we
have to think that way but when you're
planting these matches like how would I
get into me like it just is this
magnetism to where I am in perfect
setups and I'm just like nah fam and I'm
I'm a person look there's guys in a way
skill I will give up credit and I'm like
no doubt was a sometimes when I get
killed to jumbo yo that was a good one
that was my fault
yeah peaking I got picked I own it right
but there's some times I'm like there's
no way they'd be like there's no way fam
this is you are not within the realms of
reality
but what you're doing to me no and I'm
not accepting it you know it's like
that's the part now what
each death you got a question it's the
same phrase I've used this like when the
integrity of the matches at question
that's when I like it sets a little
wrong it's like yeah I'm going through
iron banner doing bounties is like a
some feel all right dudes like why does
this guy feel different it's like I know
she's like matchmaking and other stuff
like my matches where I'm like hey I'm
doing okay or I played with Ares or you
know those things will happen and then
all of a sudden I'm like dude like I
know but and the funny thing like the
interview when they interviewed him and
that thing kind of cycled around he
wasn't actually doing the aim but he was
actually just paying for wallhacks is
what he said right so he was just paying
for the wallhacks and as you said it's
like how do they always know it's like
maybe he just knows like yeah yeah but
we saw the infamous that the the
flawless to the disproportionate version
of how many were buying the bags it's
you know yeah right now it's just fixes
are not simple on stuff like this and
even for said he brought something up to
he's like they're out there trying to
like get ahead of the cheats and then
these people are apparently charging for
it and they're making Bank right now so
they're literally trying to stay ahead
of the game
yeah the interview said he was paying
like 24 bucks a month for just wallhacks
like I don't even know what the
embodying costs rah so okay it's it's
weird right now it's like we have a
season where next week and this is
another thing actually when it came to
stuff that wasn't mentioned next we've
got grandmaster coming unfortunately the
rewards there are we've talked about it
like a million not generally generally
not great yeah thrilled you are with
these I haven't done a rant video
because I probably wouldn't know where
to stop talking so I just kind of gave
up honestly I'm gonna wait till next
week and see if there's anything else
that's missed and then maybe talk about
it but generally it's I mean you have a
lack of community early communication we
talked about before were the people who
literally got to level 1068 dude got
there
mm-hmm those 35 levels don't matter you
have trials that the flawless chest I
mean it's it's pretty generally agreed
that that's not the biggest incentive
and then now the cheating it's like the
perfect storm of two big pillars of PDE
and PvP content along with the cheating
on top of it you're like it's this it's
it's the we're back in the rough times
of destiny in its season of The Drifter
curse of Osiris the lowell content
droughts of deep this springtime always
kind of hurts in this game it really
does and this is yeah this is getting a
pretty bad run for the spring doldrums
to where some people are like I think
drifter might have been better when you
look back in people joke that like
drifter so but now people are like back
that might have been mean we have
reckoning we had over Steve but we gotta
admit those rewards were way better it's
easy to jump ahead see that bonus armor
you can bring that back in the game
bring that back backs you know yeah
great guns or Night Watch spare rations
incentive really rock out didn't was
mouthpieces yeah okay it's just it's
it's in a weird place and it's
unfortunately as you said like whether
you do take a breather or you choose to
just kind of like you know bear down and
deal with it it's it's not really a
great option either way it's just like
what do you love the game enough to deal
with it right now
you might right but on the other side is
is something we should be no but can
things be fixed instantly there's no
light switch to fix them so it's it's a
patience game and unfortunately right
now when they want to be launching their
next thing next week great late Guardian
game sounds kind of cool but the Grand
Master the launch is next to it it's
like looking over here like the you know
yeah elephant in the room just like dude
you messed up and I would I would like
to real quick I would do we touch it but
I get my felwinter's it wasn't even like
I I really like that exotic and I'm like
a PvE exotic like put it back it's like
no for warlocks like you know one thing
as a warlock I've always been jealous of
a tight wait the saint-14 hell all right
the effect they jumping that enemies
jump in that bubble they got the haze
over their head they confused that's a
powerful thing this was my baby
it was such a good area control exotic
and perfect for the bull Rasputin
bunkers when they're trying to
infiltrate his own I like I would just I
had setups bro I had like about my
ornament Cole I have a build configured
for this thing and an outfit and I'm I
can't use it yes yes all they said was
it's just like like current known issues
yes so it's not like oh it's fixed oh
just it's all the current still dealing
with live yep I was gonna mention though
and this is one that may not even be
coming right now for a magnitude of
reasons like it would put it in pushback
but you gave us remember when they
mentioned going into the kind of the
tease about Grand Master's that they're
going they were going to change up the
weekly challenges to be pinnacles that
is nowhere mentioned no yeah that's true
so I have kind of a bad suspicion that
that's not coming yeah expectation we
talked about that listed it's not a
known issue and I I think if they were
going to do it they would probably
mentioned and I have a following so
that's another one of those things like
hey here's more pinnacles I will do that
later
yeah like yeah it sucks it's it's it's
it's resource it sucks Dean I haven't
mentioned you know this is the time for
it you
we're at a tough stretch you know I'm
saying oh shut up dick gamba travel Oh
salute that's the log the log odds India
gas has to meet those a lot of people to
his arm also by the way please follow
this man on twitch oh the mark I find
this guy his artist I think I've got one
of them hanging in my room somewhere
over here or yeah that wall space yeah I
met them Milan which college ECX it was
amazing but all weird a tough shot you
you know we know what it is that's why
I'm in this weird place II cuz I
remember we started this podcast we did
it it was flashpoint at the time and it
was during curse words that it was in a
bad place but this time I'm not angry
because as much as because I know what
the conditions are you know I mean when
I know where this as far as the split
and then let's be real we do know
there's a pandemic guys they can't come
into the studio right yeah they can't
they're working from home yeah you're
limited you can't work in the fullest of
capacity that you would normally work so
I they've got a lot of things going
against them so in that one thing I'm
understanding we're gonna get there just
like I said for the people who say they
quit in and all that look you're taking
a break you will be back cause like
every season launch they'll be back
every man shouldn't hell by him but it's
like but as you said it's like hey if
this is the time really hey I'm stuck at
home I feel like I'm bashing my head
against this wall hey there's a thing
that might be cool for a week cool you
get a little breather you come back damn
these destiny guns still feel good it's
like the breath of fresh air is actually
never a bad thing for this game some
people are just afraid to do it or
thought they wouldn't come back yeah I
learned from a good pack ask me you know
you take a break it's good
I got Final Fantasy seven finish look at
that not coming back for Guardian games
the best shooting
best feeling wanted it lit Ares know
when it comes to that fps and that feel
and how do the guns feel in that skybox
nothing like nothing
it's like games basically it's like
people shouldn't feel bad about taking a
break everyone starts that tweet like
I'm sorry guys it's like what are you
sorry for it's like hey I'm
check out a new game just like put a
yeah there are so many game so many
games I never Slaney horizon zero dawn
it was partially through like I was
about ten hours into breath of the world
I want to play that again I literally
want to go play through Chrono Trigger
like every day but I don't and neo2
apparently I finally it was like okay
how many missions are in this thing and
I looked there are 21 main missions
outside of stories I'm on number seven
so it was like there's a lot out there
and if you're like hey I need a break
take it and have fun if some people are
content creators they feel like they
might be forest or variety gaming trust
me it's like it's a hard thing to do and
not all that stuff's always easy but it
there are times like a it's like able to
go play a different game do it how you
still gotta take some mental health at
this point especially as we are all
basically stuck at home and to stay that
way for a little while and now even like
in Dallas that I'm in they're saying you
should basically mandate a mask if
you're out in public on tomorrow that's
starting tomorrow for Allah I was like
wait wait really
you can save fine yeah possibly fine if
you're not wearing some type of face
covering for nose and mouth for tomorrow
which is really weird Dallas is doing
that and then the governors like hey we
may be partially opening like movie
theaters with social distancing like the
week later I'm like so backwards yeah I
don't want to get into this stuff please
guys stay safe that's all I can say they
say yeah use extra precaution the cool
thing I'll ask out leave it with this um
the cool thing about being a gamer like
we are we kind of prepared yes a from
from object from an item a solo
isolations they play it as a like we
know what to do we have things we can do
to entertain ourselves during these
tough times so that's why I'm very
appreciative of being a gamer because I
share a lot of my friends who are not
they ask me like oh you know I'm like
pick up a console nobody can find a
switch right now though no you can't I
can't
cogito can't help you with them but what
I can't do is if you got your PC you can
download some cool dance game pass you
know on Xbox if you're on a budget
you get all these games you don't say
there's a ton of things you can do and
play so use this opportunity I'm saying
use the Samba thing I know you what
you've been in your backlog areas you
could touch anything it's nicely know I
can play much other than a like I have
called you have tried I haven't tried
that war zone or anything like that
yeah I got yeah yeah
free to play um I'm not the biggest
battle royal guy but I will say their
take on it is one of my favorites
oh yeah so yeah apex I haven't played it
back I put up enjoyed that apex is
another one man apex is fantastic
absolutely absolutely
a lot of stuff to play backlog or
lacquered stuff yeah take care of it
gamers do what you gotta do Bungie will
be back all point things are gonna get
addressed any worry about I'm not even
stressing it and when it does yo you
don't see how how it's gonna flip and
listen one thing I want I'll tell you
about budget that's really good is that
when they drop a trailer when they lock
it something new the feels comes back
like easy person mm-hmm you immunity
immunity sorry they've turned me on to
the artist like the music group that did
the season of the whirly trailer I have
listened to so much of that freaking
music that did the season the whirly
trailer oh dude it's so cool at some
point if I ever actually could put
together a montage that looked good and
like there's a song by that same group
dude it just fits it like perfectly you
could do this like amazing once oh no
it's like their trailers are still good
thing they got the hype that group
crushes it like the hype group
definitely gets it for sure like it's
kind of nuts how how how could we all
get more like oh we're back okay yeah
some of the best in the biz be
you know so anything else you guys want
to talk about this time I know it's kind
of open is there anything areas that you
wanted to kind of bring up for where
their topic anything about destiny or
anything kind of going on just with all
the stuff we got that we haven't touched
on yet huh no I think we kind of went
over just about everything for the most
part right yeah what Gabe joselow he
said what's one thing you like to see
upcoming observation mole PvP separated
from PvE oh can I please have like a
cinematic camera mode yeah I would love
that to do for one shooting videos for
stuff like what I just described Oh like
edit a montage or something but I just
want to drop everything off my screen
and be able to take a clean screenshot
that's all
I can't tell you how many thumbnails it
just be like clean shot don't have to
like switch between weapons or something
or all that crazy stuff that I do just
let me get a screenshot mode and just
without the over without just everything
on my screen just let me have that one
I'd be happy about that yeah I mean you
know I just want um Aidid we talked
about it before with banner I love
badass so much like what banner comes
around I always play it and um I just
want that refresh I miss when banner
used to debut you know uh Darwin's mercy
or uh you don't say like back in the day
like you you know I gotta get this this
is you know it was always because let's
be real they're not doing Interpol real
right in rituals we didn't get one Missy
right so no just need you know a kind of
quasi meta gun per archetype drop one
each you know seasonal I mean each time
banner comes around and look I know it's
resources it's probably a resource thing
you know they they they they're moving
in a hundred directions but we've gotta
put incentive back into Ben I'm I've got
all the swarm of the Ravens I need I got
all the claws of the wolf I need you
know it's time to roar of the dragon
I am sick of these days they like it's
time I need some some ban of love flavor
and in and I think whoever said it we
had on as a guest I turn them the suits
if possible into ornaments yeah so I can
I can rock it and change I can mix and
match iron banner looks you know like
enhance mods yes I agree no like iron
banner hasn't been there yeah there's a
new swap but it was like I still have
about 2,000 tokens so every time I play
them like I'll turn some in cool got
some rules alright I'll probably get
more next time so just come up
pump-action the other base so I'm happy
nice that's you
nice all you could you good yep yeah I
agree
well so what is the what is the weekend
hold for these gentlemen you guys gonna
be playing some trials grind and stuff
that you finished final fantasy what's
on the deck neato um what's next is I
will be getting back into destiny on
stadia because I'm going debut some
stadia child we gonna see what that's
about
yeah the little doodad but as far as
backlog is concerned I'm working on this
little perky game um it's called a
phantom doctrine it's an older game I'm
a big turn based strategy guy as well
that's like my second day so I'm
finishing that and I got by announcement
of one of my favorite turn-based which
is X calm chime era I'm gonna be doing
that
yours tactics is coming and um yeah
we'll do that but as far as on down
though you know rolled up we got the big
the big guns coming you know cyberpunks
and all that good stuff so I'm excited
for they have Xbox looks pretty cool
especially yeah that looks nice man so
I'm excited as far as game wise that's
what it's been yeah I'll be full time
testing starting probably back in point
but um as far as like next week with a
Cardian convoy I mean guarding games
full time I want my outfit see you give
me you got nice outfit something shiny
I'm in there squirrel
let's go Charlie object no explosive
deaths in game now
let's go with you dad that game-wise
everything what you doing game wise
Aries so I mean I'm just a dusty player
but I'm looking to be for the meat I
want to try and see if I can get my comm
screw up a little more one more legend
for unbroken I'm at like 4400 so I'm
like that Charles exchange information
how's that dedicated stadium backpack
looking room in that backpack
I would love to accompany you on your
journey Louie we would definitely be by
the way for everybody's chat this is not
for you guys he's a good guy but dad's
like it we can't all we can't all jump
in the areas carries backpack I'm making
an appointment I'm signing his
appointment book I know he's got you
know people on there hopefully could be
on your game thanks have his people
speak people well this has been a blast
guys they know we're kind of coming
towards that two hours so I always
respect everybody's time but before you
guys go well we will be raiding fallout
plays he's in the middle of trial he's
getting back into it so stay tuned this
I'm sorry but before we go I want to
shout out Aries awesome thank you for
coming on so it was an absolute pleasure
100% yeah no it's been a good time
definitely somebody with their ear to
the ground as much as you've got it's
great to get your perspective on stuff
so big time awesome stuff and also kind
of want to let Cognito
we'll get to it in a second but Aries if
you want to tell them what you got
coming up where you're the best place to
find you best place to say hey best
place to ask for space in that backpack
and let them know where they can find
you and what they can expect from you
sir
so Twitter is generally one of the
better ways to tip me up
tag me message me whatever DCP might
have some stuff cool this week media
training you see I did that I'm learning
man I'm taking beach night classes on
the DCP Twitter absolutely I will stream
okay on that Twitter a twist out TV
slash mr. Aires it's two underscores cuz
that is a number name yeah Mr underscore
underscore a are three s3f yeah and then
of course the Twitter's Mr underscore a
are three s so almost the same just one
versus two yeah I was gonna say this is
a little treat for you guys that made it
to the end of the episode so before I
send you guys the follow up plays what's
going on I wanted to let you know kind
of like wrap up see what he's got going
for the week but also wanted him to let
you guys know next week is our hundredth
episode and honestly we couldn't be
doing this about all of you guys here in
Chad so hundred is a huge huge number
and I want Cognito to let you guys know
who the guest is gonna be next week so
initial tease initial tease the shoots
easy so first of all for me again Ares
thank you for coming through spectacular
good guy in the community really fun
really respect what you do over there
for these he and Bungie those salute to
you on that I'm gonna do it talking just
stop agreeing what do you practice all
the time yeah see you back over here you
don't like how much really back to
society to campfire but it's okay you
still good still good with me that's
Luther's got your man as far as me
obviously you know are more Twitter
outlook I need all good stuff our Lord
podcast Sunday we will be doing of so
talk about what's going on and then arm
Oh tomorrow for the Final Fantasy 7 guys
I'm gonna
to a spoiler cat but enough about that
you're saying like II was saying you
know we make made a hundred man we made
a hundred you know we started this
podcast again during a time three way
Cyrus man oh sorry
virtual high five hold on you know so
it's like at the end of the day it's
like you know people like why are you
doing this this podcast when you know
the games at the person who's playing
destiny and um you know salute it to e
because you know that's my destiny
brethren you know we love this game love
support this game and it's good to see
that we I couldn't believe it a hundred
episodes so further ado you know the big
100 is coming and hopefully it it's
gonna go down and uh special guests will
be my name is by one of the one under so
salute to the law legend the fellow
warlock I'm gonna have some warlock
support I know I'm gonna be the minority
I'm just gonna like shift on out
tremendous I mean who's not a fan of my
you know we've all followed them we know
the Lord we know it's passion for the
game so look out for us should be same
bat-time back channel but no our normal
time and um I'm super pumped man it
should be really exciting so please for
those in the chat we really appreciate
you guys you guys gave us energy and fun
and we love doing this show so look to
you guys on that yeah so those guys that
made it to the end you got a little
tease of what is coming next so I'm
gonna wrap up the recording but don't
run away guys I'm gonna send you guys
over to fall out but yeah again Aires
thank you next week of course the Lord
discussion will be deep it should be a
lot of fun and if you guys don't follow
Aires follow him on twitter follow me on
Twitch same thing with Lord Cognito iron
Lords podcast me it's Eve on ttis on the
cheetah everywhere pretty simple to find
so if you trip over a cheetah and it
looks like you bought this you found me
so I'm probably gonna be working on my
pit of solo actual flawless runs working
on me I got a lot of practice what can I
say
and then probably throw in the mix as
well but for episode 99 still cannot
believe 100 is next brother we did it I
it's nuts April 17th thank you all the
rate is coming after after this but for
this week
Oh Aires by the way when I heard us say
this have you been to the end how we do
the last word so it's like yeah yeah
trying to sandal together okay so for
episode 99 April 17th it has been the
last word